Wenn jemand stirbt,
trauern die Hinterbliebenen.
Meistens jedenfalls.
Doch Anton Jakob weint seinem
verstorbenen Bruder keine Träne nach.
Hier hinauf muss ich.
Zusammen mit einer Pflegefachfrau
besucht der Betagte zum ersten Mal
das Grab von Josef Jakob.
Dessen sterbliche Überreste
wurden vor ein paar Wochen
in ein Gemeinschaftsgrab gelegt.
Ich frage mich gerade,
ob ich ihm das gönne.
Was?
Das Grab.
Weil er einfach ein Halunke war.
Er hat die Leute
immer wieder verarscht, oder?
Er ist und bleibt ein Hochstapler.
Josef Jakob starb im 70. Lebensjahr.
Er führte ein schillerndes Leben.
Ich bin sicher ein Betrüger.
Das streite ich gar nicht ab.
Mich hat im Grunde genommen nicht
die Justiz bestraft, sondern Gott.
Ich habe mein Leben wirklich
vergeudet, aber ich habe gelebt.
Kennengelernt
haben wir uns vor 15 Jahren,
als ich einen Film
über ältere Strafinsassen drehte.
Josef Jakob stand damals
kurz vor der Haftentlassung.
Ich schlug ihm vor,
seinen Weg zurück in die Gesellschaft
mit der Kamera zu dokumentieren.
Er war damit einverstanden.
Mich interessierte,
was ein Krimineller
nach jahrelanger Haft
aus seinem Leben macht.
Kann er sich ändern?
Und: Wie tickt ein Betrüger?
Davon handelt diese Reportage.
Die Strafanstalt Saxerriet
im Kanton St. Gallen.
Im Aufenthaltsraum der Strafanstalt
markiert Josef Jakob sein Revier.
Da steht angeschrieben:
"Reserviert, Jakob".
Wenn hier ein anderer sitzt,
fällt er weg
respektive fliegt er weg.
Das ist mein Platz.
Schon beim ersten Treffen
erzählt mir der 57-Jährige,
weswegen er hinter Gittern sitzt:
Er veruntreute Geld
und fälschte Urkunden.
V.a. Kleinanleger waren seine Opfer.
Das sind nicht Leute,
die 100'000 Fr., 250'000 Fr.
oder 1 Mio. Fr. geben.
Das sind Leute, die 5'000 Fr.,
10'000 Fr. oder 20'000 Fr. geben.
Die haben ihr Leben lang ...
Ich verstehe das schon.
Die haben ihr Leben lang gearbeitet
und haben 20'000 Fr. auf der Seite.
Dann kommt Jakob, macht eine Anlage
und das geht flöten.
Dann haben sie
diese 20'000 Fr. nicht mehr.
Um das ganz klar zu sagen:
Der hat das
zehn, 15 Jahre angespart.
Es ist logisch, dass der ...
... satanisch wütend wird.
Tut Ihnen das nicht leid,
dass Sie Kleinanleger ...
Doch, schon,
aber andererseits muss ich sagen ...
Ich will mich nicht rechtfertigen
oder entschuldigen, aber ...
Wenn Ihnen die Bank
ein ganzes Anlagenpapier verkauft -
versuchen Sie mal,
eine Bank anzuzeigen.
Insgesamt 15 Jahre seines Lebens
verbrachte Jakob im Gefängnis.
Aber für ihn
war der Freiheitsentzug keine Bürde.
Solange man sich
an die Grundregeln hält -
zu arbeiten,
einigermassen mitzumachen
und sich gegenüber den Angestellten
korrekt zu verhalten -,
hat man hier drin nie ein Problem.
So leid es mir tut:
Das ist kein Zuchthaus,
sondern ein Erholungsheim.
Man fragt sich manchmal,
was das soll.
Dafür gibt der Staat noch Geld aus.
Seine Zelle
muss er nun bald verlassen,
um sich dem Leben in Freiheit
zu stellen.
Austrittsgespräch
mit der Leitung der Strafanstalt.
Gefängnisdirektor Martin Vinzens
will, dass Jakob flügge wird.
Es geht noch eine Woche oder einen
Monat bis Sie entlassen werden.
Wir müssen einschränken und schauen,
wie es für Sie weitergeht.
Wir können Sie nicht hierbehalten.
Das ist mir schon klar,
dass Sie mich nicht behalten können.
Aber dann
kommen genau solche Gedanken.
Hier drin habe ich
ein einigermassen geregeltes Leben.
Ich habe drei warme Mahlzeiten,
ein warmes Bett,
ich kann fernsehen,
Stereoanlage hören,
ich kann jassen, Fussball spielen,
zwischendurch in den Urlaub ...
... und kriege erst noch
250 Fr. Taschengeld.
Das habe ich draussen eigentlich ...
Das ist traurig,
aber das habe ich draussen nicht.
Jakob sagte einmal,
dass der Strafvollzug in Saxerriet
nicht so schlimm war.
Glauben Sie ihm das?
- Das glaube ich ihm, absolut.
Das hat mit seiner Stellung
in der Insassengemeinschaft zu tun.
Das hat auch damit zu tun,
dass er Struktur hatte.
Das ist vielleicht das,
was ihm draussen fehlte:
eine fixe Struktur und klare Regeln.
Er wusste, wann er arbeiten muss
und was von ihm erwartet wird.
War er in der Strafanstalt ein Filou?
Er war schlau. Er war ein Mischler.
Das kann man sagen.
Oder ein Filou.
Das kann man so sagen.
Dort, wo etwas lief,
war er informiert.
Es gibt gewisse Geschichten,
bei denen er die Fäden zog.
Wir mussten immer etwas aufpassen.
Einerseits engagierte er sich
für die Insassengemeinschaft
und trug zum Atmosphärischen bei:
Er vertrat Anliegen von Insassen.
Er war in einem Vollzugsverlauf
sogar Mitglied des Insassenrates,
den wir damals noch hatten.
Man musste bei ihm
immer etwas abwägen,
was jetzt eigennützig
und was für die Gemeinschaft ist,
und wo versucht er, eine Lücke
zu finden, die wir nicht sehen?
Hier haben Sie ein Handy.
- Wo ist das Handy?
Das ist hier.
- Gut.
Dann kann ich das auch hier reintun.
Nach Jahren in Haft
kommt er heute frei.
So.
Herr Jakob, was für Gefühle
haben Sie, wenn Sie jetzt rausgehen?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Gemischte.
So, wir haben alles.
Herr Jakob ...- Ich sage nicht:
"Bis zum nächsten Mal."
Machen Sie es gut!
- Ja, ich gebe mir Mühe.
* Ruhige Musik *
In seiner früheren Wohngemeinde
bezieht er eine 2,5-Zimmer-Wohnung,
bezahlt durch die Fürsorge.
Ein Sozialarbeiter erwartet ihn.
Grüezi, Herr Jakob.
- Grüezi. Freut mich.
Haben Sie den Weg gefunden?
- Ja, zum Glück.
Wir haben den Auftrag
der Gemeinde Rickenbach,
Ihnen die Wohnung einzurichten.
Wir arbeiten noch daran.
Sehen Sie sich um!
Wir haben einiges geholt,
das Sie eingelagert hatten.- Gut.
Wunderbar habt ihr das gemacht.
Wunderbar! Doch, doch.
Nicht schlecht.
Ich hoffe, wir haben Ihren Geschmack
etwas getroffen.
Doch, ist gut. Super!
Sogar eine Bettdecke.
- Ja.
Das ist typisch mein Bruder.
Ja, der Kasten auch.
Nachttische hat es auch.
Der Rest wird ...
- Ja, ich kann schlafen.
Ich kann wohnen. Ich kann kochen.
Das ist das Wichtigste.
Danke, das ist wunderbar.
- Bitte.
Der erste Einkauf in Freiheit.
Man muss alles
zweimal zusammenrechnen,
um zu sehen, ob es reicht.
Das Sozialamt bezahlt ihm
für seinen Lebensunterhalt
monatlich rund 500 Fr.
Verdammt nochmals, der Cervelat
kostet auch schon 3.40 Fr.!
Wahnsinn!
Wahnsinn, Wahnsinn!
Das ist mal was anderes.
Was meinen Sie?
Ich muss alles wieder
selber besorgen und organisieren.
Ist das ein Vorteil
oder eher ein Nachteil?
Weder Vorteil noch Nachteil,
sondern ein Übel.
So, und so.
Jakob ist geschieden
und hat zwei Kinder.
Mit ihnen hat er nur wenig Kontakt.
Die meisten seiner Verwandten
und Bekannten
haben sich von ihm abgewendet.
Sie haben nicht viel Kontakt
zu Menschen. Vermissen Sie das nicht?
Nein, ich brauche keine Menschen.
Die können mir alle am Arsch lecken.
Warum denn?
- Die labern sicher schon blöd.
Profitieren ...
Profitieren und dann blöd labern.
Sind Sie enttäuscht von ihnen?
- Sicher schon.
Die Menschen von mir ja auch.
* Ruhige Musik *
Einerseits
nehmen die sozialen Kontakte
während der Strafvollzugszeit ab.
Dann kommen sie raus
und es wartet wenig auf sie.
Und in dem Alter
oder mit der Etikette, dem Stigma -
ich kann es nicht anders sagen -
das sie haben,
ob sie das wollen oder nicht,
neue Kontakte aufzubauen,
ist sehr schwierig.
Wenn dann die Ursprungsfamilie,
die Kernfamilie
sich so abgewendet hat und
den Kontakt mit ihm nicht pflegt,
oder umgekehrt,
wird es sehr schwierig.
Ein paar Wochen später
begleite ich ihn nach Kloten,
wo er seine Jugend verbrachte.
Haben Sie gute Erinnerungen
an Ihre Eltern?- Ja.
Sie wären aber
nicht so stolz auf Sie, oder?
Ja ...
Meine Mutter hätte das ausgehalten.
Und Ihr Vater?
Mein Vater war selber ...
Man sagt ja, ich sei wie mein Vater.
- War er auch kriminell?
Mhm.
Traf Sie das schwer,
als Sie das erfahren haben?
Ja, das habe ich mit sechs
oder sieben gar nicht realisiert.
Ich wusste einfach,
dass der Vater geholt wurde,
dass die Polizei ihn holte,
weil er böse war.
So erzählte uns das meine Mutter.
Aber von den Leuten her ...
- War er lange im Gefängnis?
Ich weiss es gar nicht.
Er wurde spät schlau.
Ich war schon in der Ausbildung,
als er aufhörte.
Haben Sie das Gefühl,
Sie hätten die kriminelle Ader
Ihres Vaters geerbt?
Wie sieht das aus?
- Die Brutalität.
Die Brutalität habe ich vom Vater.
- Wie meinen Sie das?
Und die Macht.
Machtbesessen.
Mein Vater
war doch von A bis Z machtbesessen.
Nach der Schulzeit habe er
Wirtschaft studiert, behauptet er.
Danach sei er viele Jahre lang
ein seriöser Geschäftsmann gewesen.
Wann kamen Sie denn so langsam
auf die schiefe Bahn?
Ich kam erst mit 40
auf die schiefe Bahn.
Warum? Was war der Auslöser?
Der Auslöser war eben ...
... die Macht,
die ich langsam kriegte.
Ich dachte, ich sei der Grösste ...
... der Welt.
- Und der Grösste sein heisst,
dass man andere
über den Tisch ziehen muss?
Nein, das nicht.
Das hat nichts damit zu tun.
Ich dachte,
mir könne nichts passieren.
Das gäbe es nicht.
Jakob sei doch unantastbar.
* Er summt eine Melodie. *
In diesem Haus
wohnt sein Bruder Anton.
So ...
Erst mal schauen.
* Er atmet schwer. *
Ja ... Vielleicht ist er zu Hause,
vielleicht nicht.
Doch, ich glaube er ist da.
Er ist da.
Herr Generaldirektor. Hoi.
So ist das.
- Anton ist der Ältere der beiden.
Ja, Wahnsinn.
- Du weisst, wie hinsetzen.
Nein, das weiss ich nicht mehr.
- Rutsch rüber, das ist mein Platz.
Jetzt ist es sowieso
langsam aber sicher vorbei.
So ...
Ja, wahnsinnig.
Du hast
eine kriminelle Energie in dir.
Das stimmt. Das sagen alle.
- Das kannst du nicht abstreiten.
Gut, eins muss man dir lassen:
Du kannst Leute gut überreden.
Ich meine,
du laberst ohne Punkt und Komma
und am Schluss glaubt er es selber.
- Da glaubt er es selbst.
Aha!
- Das ist sogar mir passiert.
Das ist angeblich so.
Wurden Sie von ihm reingelegt?
- Ja, mehr als einmal.
Aber das tut nichts zur Sache.
Ich gab es ihm
meistens nicht zurück.
Ja.
Das letzte Beispiel:
Ich liess mir die Dings auszahlen,
die Pensionskasse.
Dann kommt er und sagt,
er brauche so und so viel.
Ist ja jetzt egal, wie viel.
So und so viel für das und das.
Dann unterschrieb er mir
aber einen Fresszettel.
Darauf schrieb er, dass er mir ...
... so und so viel Tausend Franken
schulde.
Den sackte ich dann ein.
Ich habe bist jetzt
noch kein Geld gesehen.
Vergessen wir das!
Ich kann nicht sagen,
dass ich von dir enttäuscht bin.
Ich habe dir ein paarmal gesagt,
du seist ein Idiot.
Was ist das für ein Mensch,
der seinen eigenen Bruder betrügt
und darüber noch lacht?
Ich denke, seine Empathiefähigkeit
war sicher an einem kleinen Ort.
Ich glaube nicht,
dass er kein Gewissen hatte.
Er hatte sicher eins.
Ich glaube, sein schlechtes Gewissen
hat ihn auch manchmal geplagt,
aber es fehlte ihm an
Gewissensbildung oder -ausbildung.
Thomas Knecht
verfasste über Jakob ein Gutachten.
Der Psychiater hat schon
über 1'000 Straftäter beurteilt,
darunter viele Betrüger.
Ich schrieb dann von einer
kombinierter Persönlichkeitsstörung.
Diese vereinigte zwei bis drei
verschiedene Komponenten.
Das eine
war eine narzisstische Komponente,
die sich in einem
sehr starken Geltungsdrang zeigte,
in einer Tendenz,
andere auszubeuten.
Dann kam
ein hyperthymer Charakterzug dazu,
wie man so schön sagt.
D.h., dass er eine
habituelle Hochgestimmtheit hatte
und mit übertrieben grossem
Optimismus, Siegessicherheit
und auch mit viel Energie
und Tatendrang bei der Sache war.
Das trieb ihn
in seinen Aktionen voran.
Und zum Dritten zeigte er auch ...
... durch sein Leben hindurch
eine gewisse Tendenz
zu Grenzüberschreitungen,
sodass es halt doch immer wieder
zu Gesetzesbrüchen kam.
Das gibt einen Hinweis auf ...
... eine dissoziale Komponente,
wie das im Fachjargon heisst.
Sieben Monate
nach seiner Haftentlassung
steigt Jakob erneut
ins Finanzgeschäft ein.
So sieht das aus.
Das müssen wir alles renovieren,
die Scheiben ersetzen.
Hier entsteht
der offizielle Empfang.
Da gibt es vier Arbeitsplätze
für die Immobilienverwaltung.
Die Firma wird also ...
... immer grösser.
Ja, die ist nicht so klein,
wie man meint.
Das ist im Grunde genommen
das Empfangsbüro
der Managementabteilung.
Und genau dasselbe,
das ist aber geschlossen,
weil es noch ausgebaut
werden muss ...
Das ist dann
die Abteilung Immobilien.
Jakob kann überzeugend auftreten
und versteht es,
Menschen zu manipulieren.
Ich staune, wie er Leute findet,
die für ihn arbeiten.
Auch Büros zu mieten war
für den Vorbestraften kein Problem.
Anja K. ist seine erste Angestellte,
bald sollen es zwölf werden.
Wie erleben Sie Herrn Jakob so?
Ab und zu ist er aufbrausend,
regt sich zu fest auf.
Aber wir
kommen miteinander gut klar.
Was ist Ihre Funktion
in dieser Firma?
Ich bin seine Sekretärin.
Hält man es aus mit ihm?
Zahlt er den Lohn?
Ja, ja, kein Problem.
Ich bin mich schon einiges gewohnt.
Verdammt nochmals,
wo haben wir das Ding des Anwalts?
Sozialhilfe bezieht er keine mehr.
Nun nennt er sich
"Vermögensverwalter".
Das Startkapital stamme von Leuten,
die im Hintergrund bleiben wollen,
behauptet er.
Josef Jakob ist also wieder
in jener Branche tätig,
in der er früher kriminell wurde.
Was ich in den sieben
oder acht Monaten,
in denen ich draussen bin,
geschafft habe,
muss mir erst mal einer nachmachen.
Da hätte selbst Martin Vinzens,
der Direktor des Saxerriet,
die reinste Freude an mir.
Letzte Woche,
als ich aus Chur runterkam,
ging ich kurz bei ihm vorbei.
Der hat grosse Freude an mir, oder?
Obschon Martin Vinzens mir sagte,
dass die Zelle im Fall der Fälle
immer noch reserviert sei.
Die kann er noch lange
reserviert behalten.
Er ist nicht ganz begeistert,
dass Sie wieder
in diesem Business tätig sind.
Sie, ich habe in diesem "Büsnei" ...
Das ist mein Beruf.
Das ist mein Können.
Jetzt müssen Sie sich
einfach mal klarmachen,
dass ich zu den Spitzenleuten
im Management gehöre.
Und in der Betriebswirtschaft.
Hä?
Ich bin kein Laie.
Ich bin kein Trottel.
Und einer ...
- Ich bin maximal ein Betrüger.
Aber sicher kein Trottel und Idiot.
Wie meinen Sie das, "Betrüger"?
- Hä?
Dafür wurde ich ja verurteilt.
Ist das definitiv Vergangenheit?
- Das ist definitiv Vergangenheit.
Legen Sie da die Hand ins Feuer?
- Ja, sicher.
Hoffentlich verbrenne ich sie nicht.
Jetzt kommen wir schon
auf die Prognose zu sprechen
und die ist bei Betrügern
leider schlecht.
Man täuscht sich als Therapeut
oft selbst etwas.
Die Leute
erscheinen sehr therapiefähig
im persönlichen Umgang.
Sie sind sehr redegewandt
und intelligent
und auch ein Stück weit
einsichtsfähig.
Aber offenbar ist dieser Kick,
den der Betrug gibt, etwas,
worauf der Mensch ungern verzichtet.
Und darum
ist die Rückfallquote hoch.
Ich habe die Zahlen bei
meinen Internetrecherchen gesehen:
bis zu 70 % Rückfallquote.
Damit sind wir im Bereich
der homosexuellen Pädophilen.
Sie gelten so ziemlich als
die gefährdetsten Rückfallstäter.
Wir sind also da weit über der
Körperverletzung und Vergewaltigung.
Seit drei Monaten ist Josef Jakob
wieder geschäftlich aktiv.
Dann kommt dieser Mann ins Spiel,
den wir Bruno S. nennen.
S. wurde auf ein verlockendes Inserat
aufmerksam,
das von Jakob stammte.
Er suche einen Geschäftspartner,
schrieb der vorbestrafte Betrüger.
Mit einem Darlehen von 20'000 Fr.
könne man sofort einsteigen.
S. bezahlte.
Später stellte er fest,
dass die Firma
gar nie gegründet wurde.
Bruno S.
will nun gerichtlich vorgehen.
Das sind die Unterlagen,
die der Grund für die Anklage sind?
Genau, ja.
- Könnten Sie das Dokument zeigen,
das er Ihnen ausgestellt hat und
mit dem er Sie betrogen haben soll?
Er hat ein Aktienzertifikat
für die Firma ausgestellt,
die er gründen wollte -
als Sicherheit
für die Gründungskosten.
Und der Stempel?
Auf den ist er sehr stolz.
Der ist auf jedem Dokument drauf.
So sieht es echter aus.
Ist das nach Ihrem Dafürhalten
alles ein Fake?
Ja, die Firma
wurde bis heute nicht gegründet.
Wie hoch ist die Schadenssumme,
die Sie jetzt davontragen?
Ich habe 20'000 Fr.
an die Gründungskosten beigesteuert.
Und die sind jetzt versandet.
Kaum im Geschäft und schon
hat er wieder eine Klage am Hals.
Das scheint ihn
aber nicht zu kümmern.
Im Gegenteil: Er werde
nun seinerseits Bruno S. verklagen -
wegen Rufschädigung.
Jakob
hat auch eine klare Vorstellung,
was mit dem Darlehen geschehen soll.
Nein, das Darlehen
bezahle ich nicht zurück.
Er hat mir
einen Schaden angerichtet.
Um das geht es:
Er sagt, das Geld sei verloren.
Er habe Ihnen 20'000 Fr. gegeben.
Jetzt sind Sie wieder an dem Punkt,
dass es um Veruntreuung geht.
Ich kann ein Darlehen
doch nicht veruntreuen!
Erkundigen Sie sich
doch erst einmal rechtlich,
was man kann und was nicht,
Herr Bäni.
20'000 Fr. sind weg,
die er jetzt gerne zurückhätte.
Nein, er muss mir jetzt
den Schaden bezahlen.
Im Dezember 2007
wird Josef Jakob verhaftet.
Die Feiertage
verbringt er in einer Zelle
im Untersuchungsrichteramt Gossau.
Die Behörden bevormunden Jakob
im Schnellverfahren.
Amtsvormund Patrik Terzer
ist nun zuständig
für die Belange des Inhaftierten.
Er scheint wieder einiges
auf dem Kerbholz zu haben.
Herr Jakob wurde wegen Verdachts
auf mehrfachen Betrug,
mehrfache Urkundenfälschung
und mehrfache Veruntreuung
in U-Haft gesetzt.
Der Haftrichter
hat die Haft bestätigt.
Es sind also mehrere Geschädigte,
die der Grund für die U-Haft sind.
Ja, das ist richtig.
- Kann man sagen, wie viele?
Es sind drei oder vier.
Als Jakob noch in der Strafanstalt
Saxerriet seine Strafe verbüsste,
wurde er therapeutisch behandelt.
Doch die Bemühungen
um Wiedereingliederung
scheinen in seinem Fall
vergeblich zu sein.
Ich bin überzeugt, dass Herr Jakob
am Tag x aus freiem Entscheid sagte:
"Gelingt mir dieser Betrug,
kann ich ein halbes oder ganzes Jahr
gut davon leben."
Dann kommen sie
wie in eine Spirale rein.
Das ist ein Spiel
in einem sozialen System.
Es gelingt und es ist sehr einfach,
muss ich sagen.
Solche Betrugsgeschichten
laufen z.T. sehr einfach ab.
Da wundert man sich,
dass die Leute keinen Widerstand
haben oder das nicht merken.
Dann gibt das wie einen Treiber.
Es geht immer weiter:
"Das ist gelungen, ich bin gut."
"Ich mache weiter und weiter."
Das ist auch
bei einem Entlassungstag so.
Vielfach ist es einfach
eine bequeme Lebensform.
Jemand sagt: "Ich versuche es
und muss nicht geordnet arbeiten."
Bei den meisten Betrügern,
insbesondere bei denen
in den höheren Kategorien,
den sog. Weisskragendelinquenten,
sind so drei Charakteranlagen
in besonderem Masse ausgeprägt.
Man spricht auch von
der Dunklen Triade oder dark triad.
Das umfasst zum einen
den Narzissmus,
bis hin zur narzisstischen
Persönlichkeitsstörung.
Auf der anderen Seite
ist es der Machiavellismus,
oder psychologisch korrekter:
die Machiavellische Intelligenz.
Die zeigt ihm,
wie er jemanden manipulieren muss,
damit er aus dessen Verhalten
Kapital schlagen kann.
Und als Drittes
kommt der Faktor psychopathy dazu.
Das ist die
psychopathische Skrupellosigkeit.
Die ermöglicht es,
ohne grosse Reuegefühle
diese Grenze zu überschreiten,
sprich die materielle Integrität
eines anderen
zumindest zu schädigen,
um sich zu bereichern,
ohne dann
ein schlechtes Gewissen zu haben.
Josef Jakob ist aus der
Untersuchungshaft entlassen worden.
Wie fühlen Sie sich im Moment?
- Verarscht, verkannt, verkrümmt!
Oder?
Der Staat
kann sich hier alles erlauben.
Man sagt immer,
in der Schweiz sei alles super.
Das ist nicht super,
das ist miserabel.
Weiterhin Geschäfte zu betreiben,
hat man ihm verboten.
Die Auflage ist,
dass ich mich ruhig verhalten muss.
Ich darf noch zu Hause
in der Stube sitzen
und ab und zu einkaufen gehen,
sonst nichts.
Sonst
setzen sie mich wieder in U-Haft.
Bruno S.
will die 20'000 Fr. Darlehen zurück
und hat dazu noch Lohnforderungen.
Im thurgauischen Sirnach treffen sich
die Parteien vor dem Friedensrichter.
Guten Morgen, Herr Jakob.
- Guten Morgen.
Und? Wie geht es Ihnen heute?
- Schlecht. Miserabel.
Ich bin wütend.
Bei der Verhandlung
darf ich nicht filmen.
Eine Stunde später.
Zusammen
mit Amtsvormund Patrik Terzer
verlässt der Beschuldigte
das Friedensrichteramt.
Die Beweise seiner Schuld
liegen auf der Hand,
doch klein beigeben will Jakob nicht.
Wie lief es, Herr Jakob?
Es geht immer gut,
wenn Jakob etwas ...
Wie haben Sie Herrn Jakob erlebt?
Angriffig und ...
Er versuchte, zu provozieren.
Persönlich verletzend.
Fertig. Schluss.
Der Fall geht nun
an das Bezirksgericht.
Bruno S.
hat das Urteil per Post erhalten:
Das Bezirksgericht gibt ihm recht.
Jakob muss das Darlehen
von 20'000 Fr. zurückbezahlen
und zusätzlich noch einen Monatslohn.
Amtsvormund Patrik Terzer
glaubt allerdings nicht,
dass Bruno S.
sein Geld je erhalten wird.
Die rechtliche Situation
ist das eine.
Das andere
ist die faktische Situation:
Ob Herr Jakob in der Lage ist,
das zu bezahlen.
Das ist er im Moment sicher nicht.
Solange sich
die finanzielle Situation
nicht zugunsten von Herrn Jakob
ändert, kann er das nicht.
Und jemand anderes
übernimmt die Schuld nicht.
Diese 20'000 Fr. sind für den
Geschädigten also wohl verloren.
Ja, die Chancen für den Geschädigten
stehen schlecht.
Die Weste trägt er zur Strafe.
Das Bezirksgericht verurteilte Jakob
zu 500 Stunden gemeinnütziger Arbeit.
Zweimal in der Woche
muss er nun im thurgauischen
Rickenbach für Ordnung sorgen.
Was ist konkret Ihre Aufgabe
hier in der Gemeinde?
Das Quartier kontrollieren, schauen,
ob die Strassenlaternen brennen,
schauen, ob es an öffentlichem Gut
Schmierereien hat,
Bushäuschen kontrollieren ...
Ja ...
* Er lacht. *
Da hat es manchmal Papier drin.
Es gibt so Leute.
Das Wetter hält schon.
Das hält schon, das Wetter.
Vor vier Monaten begann Josef Jakob
seine Strafe abzuarbeiten.
Nun ist
der selbstsicher auftretende Mann
bereits zum Gruppenleiter
aufgestiegen.
Wie viele Leute sind in Ihrer Gruppe?
Es wären sechs,
aber zwei sind krank.
Einfach das Laub da und dort
etwas zusammennehmen.
Nicht den ganzen Platz wischen.
Die Treppe ist wichtig,
damit man sie sieht.
Es ist schon so:
Wenn ich jemanden erwische ...
... der illegal Abfall entsorgt,
wird das schon gemeldet.
Der wird gebüsst.
Sie wurden zum Polizisten, oder?
Man kann das auch so nennen.
Für das Wohl der Gemeinde.
Nein,
nur den Haufen dort zusammennehmen,
damit er weg ist.
Fertig. Schluss.
Sie haben wieder
eine gewisse Machtposition.
Als Gruppenleiter.
- Ist doch gut, oder?
* Er lacht hämisch. *
Ist schon gut, Abdullah.
Den Haufen noch zusammennehmen
und fertig.
Aber überall ist er nicht der Chef:
Dreimal die Woche
muss er am Thurgauer Beschäftigungs-
programm Opdi-Werk teilnehmen.
Die Arbeit
soll seine Resozialisierung fördern.
Zusammen mit Arbeitslosen
und Ausgesteuerten
verrichtet er einfache Tätigkeiten.
Es ist Idiotenarbeit.
Aber mit der Zeit
gewöhnt man sich an alles.
Er, der hoch gepokert
und viel verloren hat,
hadert mit seinem Schicksal.
Mich hat im Grunde genommen nicht
die Justiz bestraft, sondern Gott.
Da wurde Jakob
dann langsam einsichtig.
Vorher
wurde ich ja nicht einsichtig.
Bereuen Sie etwas?
Meine Geldgier bereue ich.
Jetzt kann ich auch
mit nichts leben.
Vorher war ich einfach der Meinung,
es ginge nicht ohne viel Geld.
Sein 60. Geburtstag.
Die Geschenke haben ihm seine Töchter
per Post geschickt.
Das Telefon bleibt stumm.
Ich bin der Einzige, der ihn besucht.
Was denken Sie am 60. Geburtstag,
wenn man über das Leben reflektiert?
Ja ...
Ich habe viel Scheisse gebaut.
Viel Scheisse gebaut.
Was ich erkannt habe -
so blöd das vielleicht klingt -,
selbst ohne Geld:
Wenn du einigermassen gesund bist
und rauskannst,
dich frei bewegen kannst
und niemanden fragen musst,
ob du darfst oder nicht ...
Freiheit
ist schon das Gold des Lebens.
Das möchte ich mir nicht verderben.
* Melancholische Musik *
Dreieinhalb Jahre später
treffen wir uns wieder.
Vor dem Wohnblock, in dem er wohnt,
will er mich beeindrucken.
Schau hier, Grübel.
Mit ihm machte ich auch Geschäfte
bei der Credit Suisse.
Mit Oswald Grübel?
- Ja, sicher.
Der war doch
der oberste Boss der CS.
Und Sie der oberste Hochstapler,
Herr Jakob, oder?
Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey!
Bäni, beherrsch dich!
Ich habe gute Geschäfte gemacht,
nicht nur Hochstaplergeschäfte.
Und ein Hochstapler bin ich nicht,
höchstens ein Betrüger.
Mit Jakob
habe er keine Geschäfte gemacht,
teilte Oswald Grübel
auf meine Anfrage hin mit.
Er könne mit bestem Wissen
und Gewissen sagen,
dass er den Mann nie getroffen habe,
sagt der ehemalige Konzernchef
der UBS und CS.
Thomas Knecht
verfasste über Jakob ein Gutachten.
Der Psychiater sagt,
Betrüger gingen grundsätzlich
nach demselben Muster vor.
Zum einen ist es eine
beliebte Taktik unter Betrügern,
den Opfern Vertrauen einzuflössen.
Man sagt: "Herr Regierungsrat",
"Herr Generalmajor" ...
Die sind alle sehr zufrieden.
Bei diesen Delikten geht es nicht
um einfache Bereicherung,
sondern es geht immer darum,
sich einen Status anzueignen,
der mit mehr Besitz - insbesondere
mit mehr Geld - verbunden ist.
In der Psychologie
gehen wir heute davon aus,
dass eine starke Triebfeder,
die dazu führt,
dass einzelne Individuen
diesen Weg einschlagen,
durchaus Minderwertigkeitsgefühle
sind, die kompensiert werden müssen.
Man muss das aber
nicht zu eng sehen:
Aufzusteigen, die Nummer 1 zu sein,
der Chef zu sein
ist objektiv eine gute Sache.
Das sieht man schon im Tierreich.
Wer eine Alpha-Position erlangt,
ist privilegiert.
Der ist beim Fressen
und in der Liebe der Erste.
Inzwischen
ist Josef Jakob 63 Jahre alt.
Er ist nun Frührentner
und bezieht keine Sozialhilfe mehr.
2'700 Fr. erhält er monatlich
durch AHV und Ergänzungsleistungen.
Er ist befreit von gemeinnütziger
Arbeit und Beschäftigungsprogrammen.
Seine Tage
muss er nun selber strukturieren.
Ihr Rentnerdasein
scheint etwas langweilig zu sein.
Ja, nein, zwischendurch gehe ich ...
Es ist halt alles eingeschränkt.
Wenn ich einen Haufen Geld hätte,
wäre das anders.
Seine Wohnung verlässt er kaum noch.
Oft ist er online.
Manchmal
hat es solche Trottel beim Jassen!
"Obenabe" mit einem Ass
und so Dummheiten. Ja ...
Furchtbar!
Du kannst jede Farbe bringen,
er hat keine.
Toter Kopf. Arschloch.
Ja, ja. 200 Punkte mehr.
So wichtig bist du doch nicht.
Die sollen sich doch selber
mal an der Nase nehmen.
Drei Monate sind seit
unserem letzten Treffen vergangen.
Jetzt überrascht er mich:
Seit Kurzem hat er eine Freundin.
* Ruhige Musik *
Die rennen davon, als ob sie
gestohlen hätten, die zwei.
Ich kann nicht mehr so schnell.
Wir verstehen uns
im Grunde genommen wortlos -
auch in den Reaktionen und all dem.
Wir können aufeinander eingehen.
Wir verstehen einander.
Jeder versteht den anderen
ohne viele Worte und so.
Es ist einfach passiert.
Wir arbeiteten beide im Opdi-Werk.
Wir gingen beide in Wil
auf das Frauenfelder-Bähnli.
Dann redeten wir jeweils zusammen.
Erst tranken wir Kaffee
und assen Gipfeli.
Mhm.
- Im Ding drin.
Zweimal flogen wir bei der Kontrolle
auf, weil wir kein Billett hatten.
Ja.
Das weiss ich noch.
Das war so komisch.
- Scheisse, du.
Aha!
Genau dann
kamen wir in die Kontrolle.
* Ruhige Musik *
So, komm.
(Schwer atmend) Anton zuliebe
ein bisschen ... sitzen.
Ah!
Komm, Anton.
Das ist das ...- Ui!
* Jakob keucht schwer. *
... was mir der Arzt
verschrieben hat.
Heute siehst du super aus,
muss ich sagen. Ohne zu lügen.
Ich lüge nicht.
- Sie macht ...
Ich muss offen und ehrlich sagen ...
- Ich habe dich schon anders erlebt,
wenn ich zu dir kam.
- Natürlich!
Als du den ganzen Tag dagesessen
bist und nicht wusstest, was machen.
Ja, du siehst super aus.
- Ich habe angefangen ...
... und mache eben so Ausflüge.
Alles, was so im Rahmen ist, oder?
- Ja.
Das muss ich ja schlussendlich
alles am Mund absparen.
Ja, sicher.
Wir haben so
eine telepathische Verbindung.
Er versteht mich, ich verstehe ihn.
Er ist nicht nur ein Kollege,
Freund oder Mann für mich.
Ich bin ein halber Apfel
und er ist ein halber Apfel.
Zusammen sind wir ganz.
- Der Apfel passt zu 100 % zusammen.
Sieh dir mal die Aussicht an!
- Mein Gott, ein wunderschöner Tag!
Ohne Bewilligung.
- Es ist so schön hier.
Da siehst du alles.
- Wow!
Das ist alles Zürich.
- Mein Gott! Superschön!
Ich mache ein paar Fotos.
- Die Stadt Zürich.
Die ganze Anstrengung,
hier hinaufzuspazieren,
ist es wert.
Es hat sich gelohnt.
- Ja.
Hier hast du
dein ganzes Leben vor dir.
Dein ganzes Leben.
- Ja, genau.
Ich geniesse jetzt mein Leben.
Ist das ... äh ...
Dieses Ding ... Das Niederdorf ...
Das ist da.
Dort, wo der grosse Kirchturm steht.
Ein Jahr später ist seine Welt
komplett auf den Kopf gestellt.
Josef Jakob hat eine nieder-
schmetternde Diagnose erhalten:
Nieren- und Blasenkrebs.
Bei mir ist es so, dass alle Ableger
der Nieren gutartig sind.
Das wissen wir.
Nur habe ich jetzt dazu
noch Blasenkrebs.
Und Blasenkrebs ist die einzige
Krebsform, die nur bösartig ist.
Davon gibt es keine gutartige Form.
Wir müssen alle einmal sterben.
Aber Sie wollen nach wie vor leben.
Ja, sicher.
Das ist mein Lebenswille.
Herr Bäni, ich sage Ihnen
ganz offen und ehrlich -
trotz all diesen Dingen und so:
Wir werden noch den 70. Geburtstag
zusammen feiern.
Todsicher! Unkraut vergeht nicht.
Bäni ...
... ist es nicht traurig, dass ...
Weder meine Kinder ...
... noch meine Geschwister
interessiert das.
Mein Bruder war neben mir.
Er wusste, dass ich notfallmässig
ins Spital gehe.
Er hat die ganze Woche, bis jetzt,
noch nicht angerufen
oder mich besucht oder so.
Das ist doch himmeltraurig.
Und die Freundin, die Sie mal hatten?
Ist das auch ...
Interessiert sich die
überhaupt noch für Sie?
Nicht?
- Nein, nein.
Ging das auch auseinander?
Ja, schon lange. Das ist ...
Meine Güte, das ist ein alter Zopf.
Das existiert
schon lange nicht mehr.
Da merkt man erst, wie lange
wir uns nicht mehr getroffen haben.
Er führte so manche Menschen
an der Nase herum,
selbst nahe Verwandte.
Nun muss er fast alleine
mit seinem Schicksal zurechtkommen.
Ich werde zur einzigen Bezugsperson
in seinem Leben.
* Beschwingte Jazzmusik *
Anton Jakob wurde von seinem Bruder
um das Pensionskassengeld betrogen.
Trotzdem hielt er immer zu Josef.
Doch jetzt empfindet er die Beziehung
als einseitig.
Er kann sich
ja auch mal bei mir melden.
Aber ich kenne meinen Bruder.
So ist er halt.
Manchmal rief er meine Mutter
zwei, drei Jahre lang nicht an.
Und wenn er anrief,
tat er das, weil er Geld wollte.
Ich finde es einfach schade.
Früher
waren wir auch immer zusammen.
Aber eben ...
Seit er aus dem Dings raus ist ...
... ist er einfach ganz anders.
Seit er aus dem Spital raus ist?
- Nein, aus dem Gefängnis.
Wieso anders?
- Ja ...
Es interessiert ihn nicht mehr so.
Ich weiss es halt auch nicht.
Ich ...
Da mache ich mit.
Träumen Sie noch vom grossen Geld?
- Ja.
Wenn du nicht spielst,
kannst du nicht gewinnen.
Das ist so.
Ein Jahr ist es her, seit man
bei ihm Krebs diagnostiziert hat.
Ich war am Mittwoch im Spital.
Sie haben nichts gefunden,
keine einzige Krebszelle.
Das heisst jetzt einfach ...
... dass ich einfach
mehr oder weniger ...
Was müssen Sie?
- Ich muss mehr oder weniger ...
... Chemotherapie weitermachen,
einmal pro Monat.
Also geht es Ihnen
wieder ziemlich gut?
Ja, wenn die Augen nicht wären.
Ich möchte ...
Ich kann nicht mal Zeitung lesen.
- Sehen Sie nicht mehr so gut?
(Erbost) Was heisst das?
Ich kann nicht mehr lesen!
Ich kann nichts!
Diese Brille kannst du wegwerfen!
Für 1'500 Fr.
Das Älterwerden,
der geringe Status und Einsamkeit
widersprechen
seinem aufgeblähten Selbst.
Er will mehr sein, als er ist.
Ich erhalte tagtäglich Angebote.
Bäni, tagtäglich.
- Was für Angebote?
Ich könnte tagtäglich
Millionen verdienen.
Ich habe die Nerven
nicht mehr dafür.
Ich habe die Nerven für das Gejammer
meines Bruders nicht mehr.
Was bedeutet Ihnen Ihr Bruder?
Was bedeutet mir mein Bruder?
Was bedeutet mir meine Tochter?
Was bedeutet mir meine Ex-Frau?
Was bedeutet mir mein Bruder?
Was bedeutet ...
Ich bei mir. Ich für mich selber.
Fertig. Schluss. Aus. Amen.
Ich bin der Meinung,
dass es am besten wäre,
wenn man mich
langsam beerdigen würde.
Er sieht sich in der Opferrolle.
Hier klingeln sie nur ...
Hier klingeln sie nur,
wenn sie etwas von mir wollen.
Oder?
Die Leute verkehren nur mit mir,
wenn sie etwas Positives
herausholen können.
Wenn sie Zigaretten, Geld
oder sonst etwas kriegen.
Wenn sie sich bei mir
zu Tode fressen können,
wenn sie zu Hause nichts haben.
Sie waren doch auch jahrelang
auf den eigenen Vorteil aus
bei anderen Menschen.
Sicher nicht auf diese Art.
Ich zog ihnen die Kohle
aus dem Arsch.
Betrüger
haben ein verzerrtes Selbstbild.
Sie manipulieren andere
und sind Egoisten ohne jede Hemmung,
sagt Psychiater Thomas Knecht.
Wenn es darum geht, Gefühle
angesichts der anderen zu empfinden,
sich in andere einzufühlen, nicht
nur seine eigene Gemütsverfassung,
dann haben wir ein gewisses Defizit.
Das ist bekannterweise
v.a. mit der dissozialen
Persönlichkeitskomponente verbunden
und auch ein Stück weit
mit der narzisstischen,
wenn man so ichbezogen ist,
dass die eigene Befindlichkeit alles
ist und die der anderen nichts.
Oh!
Bei der eilt es.
Mit einem Sparbillett
geht es heute auf den Zürichsee.
* Schiffshorn *
Den Krebs
vermag er auf Distanz zu halten,
aber sein Augenleiden
hat sich verstärkt.
Deshalb trägt er eine Spezialbrille.
Einmal mehr
bin ich der Einzige an seiner Seite.
Dass Sie immer alleine sind,
kann man sagen,
ist auch etwas selbst verschuldet.
- Ja, sicher.
Sicher.
Vor 20 Jahren hätte ich nicht
mit Ihnen diskutiert,
Sie nicht mal gegrüsst.
Aber ist egal.
Hä?
Wieso denn nicht?
Ja,
weil ich bei den oberen 20'000 war.
Dann wäre jemand wie ich
zu wenig gewesen?
Sie müssen verstehen:
Ich habe mit Jelzin verkehrt ...
... mit Milosevic, mit Bundesrat ...
... Gnägi, mit Bundesrat Celio ...
Überprüfen lässt sich das nicht,
denn alle aufgezählten Personen
sind gestorben.
Was stimmt? Was nicht?
Das ist für mich
schwer einzuschätzen.
Einmal behauptet er,
er bereue seine Betrügereien,
dann wiederum
redet er seine Taten klein.
Es sei ja kein Blut geflossen.
Mit Bereuen, Bäni,
kann ich es nicht mehr gut machen.
Bereuen Sie es denn nicht?
- Hä?
Bereuen Sie es nicht?
Ich sage es Ihnen so:
Ich wurde letztens gefragt ...
... was ich anders machen würde,
wäre ich noch einmal 20.
Ich sagte:
"Gar nichts."
Ich würde wahrscheinlich
denselben Scheiss durchmachen,
den ich schon durchgemacht habe.
Ich sehe zwei Punkte,
die man da erwähnen muss:
Einerseits ist das
Unrechtsbewusstsein relativ klein.
Für den Betrüger ist es leichter
als für einen anderen Delinquenten,
sich selbst einzureden,
es sei ja gar nicht so schlimm.
Seine Art Geschäfte zu machen,
unterscheide sich
ja gar nicht gross davon,
was andere erfolgreiche
Geschäftsleute und Manager machen.
Das ist das eine.
Das andere ist das, was ich mit dem
Gambler-Effekt vergleichen würde.
Es tut gut,
auf eine so leichte Art zu gewinnen.
Es ist eine Selbstbestätigung,
dass man sogar den grossen Herren
in der Wirtschaftswelt
Geld abknüpfen kann,
dass man mit denen auf Augenhöhe
steht, wenn nicht sogar darüber.
Kürzlich ist er in eine Wohnung
mit Gartensitzplatz umgezogen.
Doch sein Leben wird von erneuten,
gesundheitlichen Problemen
überschattet.
Ja ...
Es stand eine Kontrolle
im Spital an.
Die Jahres-
oder Zweijahreskontrolle.
Dann war halt ...
Ich erschrak selber darüber,
als sie mit der Kamera raufgingen
und zeigten, wie die Blase aussieht.
Alles zerfressen.
Wie ist die Diagnose jetzt?
Der bösartigste ...
... Blasenkrebs, den es gibt.
* Melancholische Musik *
Ich mache hier zu.
Nicht nur Blase und Nieren
sind vom Krebs befallen,
auch in der Prostata und Harnröhre
fanden die Ärzte Ableger.
Dazu hat er noch ein Herzleiden.
Ich mache mir keine Gedanken.
Weil ...
... erstens lebe ich zu gerne
und zweitens vergeht Unkraut nicht.
Nur schon das Beten am Abend:
"Gib mir die Kraft und Gesundheit,
damit ich alles
nach deinem Wunsch erfüllen kann!"
"Gib mir Gesundheit, gib mir Kraft!"
Sehen Sie sich mein Leben an!
Mein Leben verlief 40 Jahre lang
wie ein Traum.
Und ... äh ...
Sollte ich 70 werden ...
... habe ich die 40 Jahre verbüsst.
Aber todsicher, Bäni. Todsicher.
Nur mit Schmerzen ...
... krebskrank und mit ...
Der todkranke Josef Jakob bat mich,
ein Treffen zu organisieren.
Er möchte Martin Vinzens
noch einmal sehen,
den Direktor
der Strafanstalt Saxerriet.
Hier verbüsste Jakob
eine jahrelange Strafe.
Herr Jakob.
- Vinzens.
Hallo, wie geht's?
- Es muss, mit Krebs und Herzleiden.
Aber einigermassen erträglich?
- Ja, einigermassen erträglich.
Wenn ich die Kraft hätte,
würde ich zurückkommen.
Würden Sie zurückkommen?
Verstehe ich das richtig?
Hier ging es Ihnen besser
als draussen?
Es macht keinen Unterschied.
Ging es Ihnen fast besser,
als Sie hier waren?
Ja.
Ich habe den Strafvollzug ...
... als positiv erlebt.
- Mhm.
Es ist schon verrückt,
wenn man sagen muss,
dass es einem im Saxerriet fast
besser ging als dann in Freiheit.
Ich muss schnell Münzen holen.
Das ist wahrscheinlich
noch nie vorgekommen:
Der Direktor
macht dem Gefangenen einen Kaffee.
Das gab es vorher nicht.
Das ist schon speziell.
Für mich ist das heute wieder ...
... ein schöner Tag.
Ich sehe Sie wieder einmal.
- Das müssen Sie noch einmal sagen.
Und ich kann mit Ihnen diskutieren.
Ich sage es Ihnen ...
- Jetzt können Sie alles ...
Ich habe hier drin
mit Handys gehandelt.
Sie können alles beichten,
was wir nicht gemerkt haben.
Mit Handys gehandelt.
Alle 14 Tage hatte ich
entweder hier oder in der Hand ...
... ein Handy reingeschmuggelt.
So frech war ich.
Dann haben wir nicht gut gearbeitet.
Sie haben offenbar nichts gelernt.
Nein, absolut nichts. Hoffentlich.
- Aha, absolut nichts.
Im Schnitt habe ich ...
... nebenbei ...
... 2'000 Fr. bis 2'500 Fr.
verdient.
Jetzt fantasieren Sie aber,
Herr Jakob.
Nein.
Legen Sie es darauf an,
dass wir Sie wieder einsperren?
Ja, was wollen Sie mich einsperren?
Ja, Sie waren ... Sie waren ...
... schon immer ein Ganove.
Und Sie blieben es offenbar.
Ja, das bin ich geblieben -
bis jetzt.
* Melancholische Musik *
Ja, Wahnsinn.
70 Jahre alt ist er inzwischen.
Geschwächt von seiner Krankheit
möchte Jakob
ein letztes Interview geben.
Wir können das abschliessen.
Der Abschluss ist folgender:
Ich habe mich
um ungefähr das Zehnfache ...
... gebessert.
Ich mache keine Dummheiten mehr.
Ich hole nichts mehr
in die Dings rein ...
Das Einzige, was ich noch mache,
aber das sage ich nur Ihnen ...
... ist, Geld zu sammeln.
Geld sammeln?
- Ja.
Immer, wenn bei mir Geld ...
... aufs Dings kommt ...
... aufs Postfach ...
... geht Jakob ...
* Er keucht. *
... Geld sammeln. Oder?
Sie sind also sparsam.
Was wollen Sie sagen?
- Hä?
Damit gehe ich über Weihnachten
und Neujahr in die Ferien.
Wohin?
- Hä?
- In den Süden.
Dazu wird es nicht mehr kommen.
- An die Wärme.
Das war das letzte Mal,
dass ich ihn gesehen habe.
* Melancholische Musik *
* Kirchenglocken *
Josef Jakob
starb im Alter von 70 Jahren
an den Folgen seiner Krankheit.
Nun liegen seine sterblichen
Überreste in einem Gemeinschaftsgrab.
Eine Inschrift mit seinem Namen
fehlt.
Er wurde ohne
kirchliche Abdankungsfeier begraben.
Sind wir auf dem richtigen Weg?
- Ja.
Erst Wochen nach Jakobs Tod
besucht sein Bruder
zum ersten Mal dessen Grab.
Er wird von einer Pflegefachfrau
begleitet.
Anton Jakob
lebt inzwischen in einem Altersheim.
Konnten Sie ihm verzeihen?
Ja ...
Verzeihen
kann man vielleicht nicht sagen.
Aber ich habe es jetzt
einfach akzeptiert.
Sind Sie traurig,
dass Ihr Bruder gestorben ist?
Das würde ich nicht behaupten.
Ich glaube kaum,
dass ich traurig werde,
weil der nicht mehr da ist.
Warum?
Weil er das einfach verdient hat -
nach all dem,
was er sich geleistet hat.
Und so
endet die Geschichte eines Mannes,
der als Betrüger durchs Leben ging.
Einsamkeit war der Preis,
den er dafür bezahlte.
Umso mehr freute er sich,
dass ich mich für ihn interessierte.
Josef Jakob erlaubte mir, diesen Film
nach seinem Ableben fertigzustellen.
Ein Vermächtnis von einem, dem wohl
nicht viele eine Träne nachweinen.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
puretype gmbh - 2021